a warm welcome to all our viewers and
Anjali from simply learned and today
I'll be taking you through loops in
Python so first we look at what exactly
loops are then we look at the various
varieties of loops which are why loop
for loop and nested loop we'll also look
at some of the loop control statements
and finally we'll wrap it up with an
exercise on printing a certain pattern
so let's begin
so Jacob wants to print his name ten
times now there are two ways of doing
this one is he can literally give ten
print statements for printing his name
or he could use a smarter method and he
could have just one print statement and
somehow repeat the execution of this one
statement now this is where loops come
in so a loop is basically an instruction
that repeats multiple times as long as
some condition is met so J could simply
use a loop to execute that one print
statement ten times now in Python we
have three main types of loops there's
the while loop the for loop and finally
the nested loop now before we move into
these loops let's look at the flow of a
loop so the dot at the top represents
the start of the program now all the
statements of the program are executed
one by one until a condition for the
loop is encountered now if this
condition results in true the statements
within the loop are executed and once
again the condition is checked now this
loop continues as long as the condition
is satisfied the minute the condition
fails the program's control exits out of
the loop and all these statements
following it are executed so now that we
got a basic idea of what loops are and
how they run let's look into are three
basic loops the first is the while loop
so the while loop is used to repeat a
section of code an unknown number of
times until a specific condition is met
so suppose Jake did not want his name to
be printed exactly ten times but until
the end of the page in this case you can
use while loop and the condition would
be print until end of
Paige is reached so what is the syntax
of a while loop you have the keyword
while followed by the expression or the
condition that has to be met and then
colons and following the colons on the
very next line you can start the
statements which will exist within your
while block intended slightly to the
right now let's look at a short demo to
better understand how while loop works
so I'll move into PyCharm so we'll write
a very simple program that ask the user
to enter a multiple of seven and the
program keeps doing this until a
multiple of seven is correctly entered
by the user so if the user enters say 14
or 21 you simply print yes this is a
multiple of seven but on the other hand
if the user enters say ten or twelve or
any other number which is not a multiple
of seven you got to take the input again
so let's begin first I'll take an input
from the user and I'll store this in my
variable value so in Python every input
that you take from the user is
automatically taken in the string format
and you need to convert this into int so
that is what this int function is for
and within the braces you take the input
now we need to make sure that the number
entered by the user is a multiple of
seven and if it's not we need to take
the input again so here's where the
while loop comes in we check the modulus
of Val again seven and if this is not
equal to zero that means if Val divided
by seven does not give a remainder
that means Val is not a multiple of
seven so in this case again we need to
take the input from the user
so we'll repeat our first line once
again
let's have a look at the syntax a while
before we move ahead so we have the
first keyword which is why and then Val
mod seven is not equal to zero is a
condition now every time this condition
results in true this statement is
executed so this is the only statement
within the while loop now we need to
also take care of the condition where
the value is a multiple of seven so this
will come under else now if you've gone
through other programming languages this
might be something new you're coming
across cuz else is always used with if
you don't use it with while or for or
any other loop statement as such but in
case of Python this can be done else :
and next line print so if the user did
finally enter a multiple of seven we
just say that this number is a multiple
of seven so when you're printing the
value of a variable within a sentence
this how you do it wherever you want the
value to appear in the sentence place
the placeholder have the placeholder for
the variable there so in our case Val is
an integer type of variable therefore we
have the placeholder percentile D if val
was a string type will have percentile s
and after the quote you put the modulus
sign followed by your variable name if
you have two or more variables after the
modulus sign within brackets you can
enter your variable names separated by
commas like this so I just have one
variable and that's it now let's run
this save it first
you
so your first line enter a multiple of 7
is printed let's enter 18 which is not a
multiple of seven and see what happens
so once again as we wanted the input
needs to be taken from the user and this
will continue until you do give a
multiple of seven so now if I give 14
there you go 14 is a multiple of seven
and a program has successfully
terminated now to better understand the
flow of while loop let's debug this
program so the first thing you do is you
keep a breaking point on your first line
and then you go to run and debug the
program so in debugging we basically see
the execution line by line and to do
this we press f8 so after your breaking
point is placed press f8 and the first
line is printed in your console so let's
given an input say 87 let's go back to
our debugger as you can see here the
value of Val is now 87 and we have moved
to the second line where Val mod 7 was
checked against zero and because it was
not zero this means that the Wild's
condition is true and you move into the
statements within the while loop so now
we have reached the third line where we
are taking the input from the user again
so once again we do f8 and as you see
the user input needs to be taken again
so now I'll give 42 which is a multiple
of 7th enter and it goes back to the
while loop because now once again it
needs to check if Val mod seven is not
equal to zero and as you can see here
now the value of Val is 42 we press f8
you'll notice how we jumped from line
two to line five this because this time
42 mod seven was equal to zero so the
wild resulted in false and the statement
right after false which is your else is
what got executed so now you have the
execution for the last print statement
and if we press f8 once again you see a
programs terminated with the final
output 42 is a multiple of seven so
I hope you understood while loop let's
move on to the next loop which is the
for loop now for loop is used to iterate
over a sequence the sequence could be a
list it could be a couple it could be a
array a string or it could even be a
range basically if you have certain
elements arranged one after the other a
for loop can be used to iterate over
these elements so now let's look at the
syntax of for loop you have the for
keyword followed by counter so counter
is basically a variable say you want to
repeat your name 10 times what you do is
you always keep track of the number of
times you've already repeated your names
in your fingers and that is exactly what
a counter is to a for loop a counter
keeps track of the position that you are
in in the sequence after counter you
have another keyword in and then you
have the sequence so the sequence you
can literally give your list there or
you can have the variable which stores
your list double array or string now
let's move into a demo for the for loop
once again I'll open my pycharm so now
we will write a program to iterate over
a list now I'll store my list in the
variable X and my list will have the
elements 1 comma 6 comma simply learn
[Music]
now using the for loop
I'll iterate over X so my counter in
this case will be I in and my sequence
which is X always followed by the colon
and now I'll just print I let's save
this and run it so as you can see here
the elements of X are printed there's 1
6 followed by simply learn so what it
does is basically when you give I in X I
assumes the value of the first element
in X prints this value and every time
you go back to the for loop I is
incremented by 1 so the second time you
reach the for loop I is now holding the
value 6 and the third time I holds the
value simply
now the same thing can be done with just
a string so if X is equal to simply
learn which is a string and we run this
code now you see all the letters of the
string are printed one by one so in case
of strings I hole C value of each
character in the string right from the
beginning up to the end now Python also
allows nested loops and by nested loops
we mean loops within loops so now there
are various ways that nested loops could
be implemented it could be a for loop
within a for loop it could be awhile
within a while loop a fall within a
while loop or a while within a for loop
so in our demo for nested loops we'll
see one of the most popular applications
for it which is accessing the elements
of a matrix
so first we'll begin with creating a
matrix store my matrix in variable X and
my matrix will have two lists one would
contain the elements 1 2 3 and the other
will be of alphabet ABC now with the
matrix as you can see there are two
lists within it
our first for loop will iterate over the
elements of X so the range is X so when
I see that I iterate over the elements
of X I basically takes the value of the
first list in the first iteration and
the second list in the second iteration
now a second for loop which is nested
within a first for loop will iterate
over the values within that list so for
J in I let me explain this once again so
if I points to your first list
J will be used to iterate over every
element in your first list and in your
second iteration I will point towards
your second list and J will iterate over
every element in your second list
we'll just print out the elements and
let's run this just increase the size of
my console here run it and as you can
see the elements of your matrix are
printed one two three ABC now what if
you want one two three to be printed in
one line and your next list elements
which are ABC to be printed in the next
line so every time you print J you do
not want a next line so put n equal two
codes what this does is that it removes
the newline which is automatically put
by the print function in python and once
you exit the inner for loop you're
basically moving to the second list so
now you want a change in line and hence
I just put a print statement here let's
run this and as you see one two three
ABC now nested loops can get a little
confusing with the flow for this purpose
we'll also debug this code
place your braking point on the first
line and debug f8 now as you see X holds
the two lists one two three ABC now f8
again and a first for loop is executed
and I now holds the value one two three
as you can see here we now have moved
into a second for loop and J holds the
value one so I right now points to our
first list in X and J points the first
element in our first list in X now once
we execute the print statement your
first element gets printed and once the
first element is printed you go back to
your inner for loop
and now 2 gets printed once again you go
back to your inner for loop 3 is printed
and again you go back to your inner for
loop now you have reached the end of the
ayat list the next time you click the f8
you're basically jumping over to the
print statement at the end which shifts
to a new line and now and now we are
back to our outside for loop so out of
four loops counter which is I now points
to the second list in X which is ABC so
when we are back so we click f8 again
and J has taken the value of the first
element in your second list which is a
once again f8 and as you can see a is
printed in the console below we are back
to our inner for loop print plus a feed
again B gets printed again we are back
to our inner for loop and C gets printed
now we have reached the end of our
second list too so the next time we
press f8 the control skips to the last
print statement which is a newline
statement and it goes back to the outer
for loop now here to the counter I has
reached the end of our matrix X so once
again when we hit the F 8 a program
terminates now as we saw loops have a
certain flow and you might come across
certain scenarios where you want to
break out of this flow so this is where
the loop control statement comes in we
look at the two most popular loop
control statements use in Python the
first is the break keyword suppose you
are executing a loop for seed ten times
but if a certain condition occurs
between our first and our 10th iteration
we want to immediately exit out of the
loop in this case you can use the break
statement so I will just move back to my
PyCharm and show you a simple demo on
how play can be used
so the first thing we do is we create a
string store this in my variable X now
to iterate through the string of course
we'll use the for loop for I in X and :
now what we want a program to do is that
it should print only the first sentence
of a string so it should print just hey
there and as we can see in our string
here here there is followed by a full
stop so we can say that whenever we
encounter the full stop we'll break out
of the loop and print no more so if I is
equal to full stop
we break out of the loop and for every
other case will simply print I which is
the character in our string so let's run
this code now as you can see here all
our characters here there are printed
and once I is equal to full stop the if
statement results in true and we
encounter the break statement which
breaks the loop so as you can see her
every character of a string is printed
on a new line which is not what we want
so in a print statement put end equal to
Coates and this will ensure that you are
not going to a new line every time
let's run break again Anya here there
appears in the single line so once again
I will repeat how the flow of this
program works goes to the for loop I it
rates over every character in the string
hey there how are you and every time I
is checked against a full stop
so if I is not equal to equal to the
full stop we come to this print
statement which is a part of our outer
for loop and only the character is
printed we go back to a for loop every
time and I is incremented so it keeps
pointing to the next character and once
I is equal to equal to full stop we
encounter the break statement which
breaks the control to outside the loop
and a pro
terminate successfully now we'll have a
look at a second loop control statement
which is continued so in some cases when
a certain condition occurs within a loop
you do not want to break out of the loop
but you want to skip that particular
iteration for the loop so in this case
you can use continue once again we'll
move back to PI chomp so I can show you
a short demo on how continue works now
for our demo for the continue keyword we
want to print all the numbers in a list
which are less than 10 so to iterate
through a list we have four I in and our
list which is 1 13:56 4 6 now let's see
how we write this program without using
the continue statement first so within
the for loop if I is greater than 10
which is basically the number we do not
want to print we have no action to give
under if because there's nothing we want
to do if the number is greater than 10
and under else which is if the number is
not greater than then we'd want to print
it now this seems simple but the problem
here is that you cannot leave if without
any action this would result in an error
as you can see here there's an intent
expected and this is where continue
comes in so if I is greater than 10 you
continue so basically you skip all
statements after this continue statement
in the for loop and when you insert your
continue statement the control
automatically goes back to the for loop
so in that case you do not even require
your else statement here and you can
just have print under your for loop so
once again I will explain how this works
I iterates over our list so I points to
our elements 113 56 4 & 6 in each
iteration respectively and every time we
check if I is greater than 10 if I is
greater than 10 we do not want to print
I we just say continue so the control
goes back to the for loop and if I is
not greater than 10 that is if I is any
number between 0 to 9 we simply come
here and the number
is printed so I'll save this and let's
run this code so as you can see here one
gets printed four and six is printed we
can debug this too just to see how the
flow works so place your breakpoint here
and debug continue as you can see first
time is pointed to one now I is checked
if it's greater than ten of course I is
not greater than ten so the control
skips to the print statement and if you
go back to the console press f8 you can
see one gets printed now the control
goes back to the for loop and this time
I is 30 is 30 in greater than 10 yes 13
is greater than 10 so the if condition
is satisfied and we reach the continue
statement
so once the continues executed as you
can see here the control transfers back
to for loop and I moves on to the next
iteration and I currently holds the
value of 56 so this way all your numbers
which are less than 10 gets printed one
by one now that we have gone through
some of the basic concepts of loops
let's get into the exercise so here we
want to print a pattern of an inverted
triangle using Asterix
now our program should take the number
of rows from the user and based on that
number it should print this pattern for
example if the user enters for a pattern
should have four rows and if the user
enters three a pattern should have three
rows so let's move to pycharm and begin
writing our code the first thing to do
is we need to take the input for the
number of rows from the user so I'll
store the input in my variable X now we
need to figure out how from the number
of rows we can find out the number of
Asterix that need to be there on the
first line of a pattern so let's go back
to our pattern as you can see here if
you need to print the pattern of four
rows our first row would have seven
Astrix as
kyndra would have five Asterix a third
row would have three Asterix and our
last row which is a fourth row would
have one Asterix so at every row one
astrick from either side is remove and
instead of that a space is added so in
the second row we have a space in the
beginning followed by five asterisks and
then a space again and the similar
manner in a third row we have two spaces
in the beginning followed by three
asterisks and two spaces again but how
do we know how many Astrix to begin with
so if our number of rows is four we
begin with seven Astrix that is four two
times which is eight minus one in the
similar way if we have three rows then
our first row would contain five Asterix
which is 3/2 times that is six minus one
and if you draw this pattern similarly
for any number you'd notice that for
every number the first row would contain
the number of rows into two minus one
Astrix so if we go back to a code we
know now that a formula is 2x minus 1
for the number of asterisks in our first
row so let me name this as Y and Y holds
the value 2x minus 1 now let's store the
value of y another variable say n this
because while Y value will remain
constant will require n to menu play the
value throughout a program so n will
basically signify the number of Astrix
in each row so if we just look at our
first row all the N Astrix need to be
printed so say for I in range of 1 to n
plus 1
print your Astrix so the range function
basically takes all the numbers from one
to the end limit except that it excludes
the end limit so if I would write here 1
comma n then all the numbers from 1 to N
minus 1 would only be taken since I want
n as tricks and not n minus 1 as tricks
my end limit would be n plus 1 now this
takes care of the Astrix but what about
the spaces before and after the Asterix
so let's go back to our pattern and as
you see here if you consider the spaces
all the rows have equal number of
characters that is in case of a first
example the first row has n 7 characters
or 7 Asterix the second row has 5 Astrix
and 2 spaces on either side so that's
basically 7 characters again so the
number of spaces is the number of Astrix
in that particular row minus the number
of Asterix in the first row so enough
first row obviously we have no spaces in
our second row we would have 5 minus 7
spaces that is 2 spaces
therefore the formula for finding the
number of spaces would be the number of
rows minus the number of Astrix in that
particular row so in terms of our
variables the formula would be Y minus N
and let me store this in a variable
space but here's the thing the entire Y
minus n spaces are not put together
they're divided into two parts Y minus n
by 2 spaces come before the asterisks
and y minus n by 2 spaces come after the
asterisks so the value of our space
variable would be Y minus n divided by 2
now I'm putting two slashes here because
one slash all the divides gives you the
floating-point number when you insert
two slashes it gives you the integer
value so now before our asterisks
we'll print space number of spaces and
after our Asterix are printed we'll
again print space number of spaces so
for J in range of 1 comma space plus 1
print a space and exclude the newline
and after the Astrix are printed again
print your spaces so 4k in range 1 comma
space plus 1 print a space so this takes
care of each row beings Asterix followed
by spaces now this would only print one
row we want this to be repeated X number
of times another way we can put this is
that we want the rows to be printed
until we reach a row with a single
astrick and as we mentioned earlier and
holds the number of Asterix in each row
so using while loop we can say that we
want the following statements to be
printed as long as n is greater than or
equal to 1 we indent everything within
our while loop so that looks complete
but here's the thing
where are you changing the value of n so
every time as you mentioned earlier when
we were going through the pattern the
number of Asterix in each row reduces by
2 so after you print an entire row
reduce the value of n by 2 so that looks
right now let's run this code enter the
number of rows let's say 4 okay
something's off here all the Astrix are
printed in a single line which is not
what we want
why is this so so if you go back to your
code you'll notice that we have
terminated each print statement with the
nth parameter which means that it skips
going to the next line but at the end of
every row that we print we do want to go
to the next line so in our while loop at
the end of printing the rows let's add a
print statement save this and run it
again again the
something wrong with earth pattern
although the number of Asterix are
correct the spacing seems of if you
notice closely the number of spaces is
always maintained constant there are
equal number of spaces on this side for
every row this because he formula to
assign the value for the number of
spaces is outside our while loop this
should be inside our while loop because
the value of n keeps changing in every
iteration so let's move this into the
while loop run a program again and there
you go a pattern is printed let's try it
again with another number say 11 so a
program can print this pattern for any
number and with that we come to an end
of a python tutorial on loops if you
have any doubts regarding this please
post them in the comment section below
and we'll definitely get back to you if
you liked this video please hit the like
button also subscribe to our channel if
you have not yet see y'all next time
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here